j'étais là le premier jour de où il a
commencé sur scène et je l'ai emmené du
Point Virgule un an après au Palais des
Glaces un an après trois semaines
fermées à l'Olympia 18 19 20 ans
c'est violent très violent il faisait la
classe en même temps je sais est-ce que
tu as été surpris qu'est-ce qui lui est
arrivé ou pas du tout parce qu'il est
arrivé non franchement
je savais que ça allait pas bien j'ai un
peu fait comme Jean-Marie si vous disais
l'autre jour un moment Jean-Marie Bigard
qui a un moment les routes se séparent
et en plus moi j'ai pas de leçon de
morale à donner à Pierre Palmade puisque
j'ai connu les problèmes qu'ils
rencontrent mais j'ai eu un moment où
j'ai pris le chemin pour arrêter ces
histoires et tu t'en rappelles sur moi
bien sûr
tu trouves toi qui a un lynchage
médiatique autour de lui alors ça c'est
insupportable d'abord le préambule il
est simple
il y a un coupable et des victimes c'est
clair et que on interprète ce que je
vais dire j'ai cherché plein de SMS ou
de sur Facebook parce que je venais en
me disant oh là là oh là là donc je suis
vraiment en pleine compassion du côté
des victimes mais je trouve qu'on en
fait trop et que ça fait encore deux
autres victimes le trop j'ai pas trop
mais imaginez-vous la famille qui vient
de vivre ce drame et qui ne peut pas
ouvrir la télévision sur n'importe
quelle chaîne sans que l'on foute ce
drame dans la gueule donc ça c'est une
chose la deuxième chose et c'est là où
je voulais en venir c'est que je pense
il a rien à faire en toute façon
provisoire je voudrais pourquoi en
prison de penser qu'il doit pas aller en
prison non non
en tout cas actuellement non il doit
être hospitalisé enfermé avec l'hôpital
sous-écrou mais dans un vrai hôpital pas
dans l'hôpital de la santé pas de la
santé de Fresnes où tout le monde sait
que c'est un hôpital le sang moyen déjà
l'hôpital normal n'a pas beaucoup de
moyens donc et ensuite je veux dire
pourquoi
parce que si on veut qu'il y ait un
procès
il faudrait-il qui est tous les
combattants autour de la table et j'ai
très peur connaissant vous savez quand
j'ai rencontré à 18 ans il était
toujours meurtri pas la disparition de
son papa il est très entouré par sa
maman son premier spectacle s'appelle ma
mère aime beaucoup ce que je fais et
tout dernièrement il a sorti un livre
vous rendez compte 30 ans après
dites pas mon père je suis célèbre enfin
un truc comme ça c'est à qui n'a
toujours pas bouclé le problème est-ce
que j'ai peur vraiment et sincèrement
parce que j'ai de la tendresse pour lui
on pourra pas me l'enlever mais je fais
j'ai peur c'est qu'il soit pas
là le jour sonnerie le jour du match et
bien sûr si il est soigné et si c'est
dans deux ans il sera obligatoirement
dans une forme meilleure et il a il
devrait répondre de ses actes et qu'on
se calme et Monsieur le Procureur de
Melun pourtant vous avez été c'est une
très belle ville là tout le monde s'aime
et tu sais pourquoi parce que
c'est sympa
juste Claude est-ce qu'il avait tu viens
tu t'es en train de dire qu'il est pour
toi il a des tendances suicidaires donc
il faut vraiment qu'il soigne avant
sinon il pense que il y a le risque
qui veut prendre ce risque là
attention je le défends pas
mais remettons-le ensemble pour que le
moment venu il puisse être là pour
répondre de ses actes sinon vous rendez
compte la triple peine pour la famille
pas de
aujourd'hui toi tu penses que c'était
c'était inévitable ce qui s'est qui est
arrivé un drame ou pas l'accident
AVC samedi changer toujours pensé ça
arriverait un jour
quand tu prends des quantités pareilles
il y a un moment
toi tu as déjà eu des
soirées comme ça et dis-nous la vérité
en 2007 il s'appelle Ling brisée la
ligne de Cook et la ligne de la vie mais
les deux vont pas ensemble pierre
de la cocaïne sa vie elle est brisée
son producteur historique tu me dis tu
la connais à 19 ans ça non tu as cognac
il a basculé dans la dans la alors moi
je l'ai su au bout d'un an un peu plus
d'un an vous étiez au Festival de Cannes
on mange avec des journalistes hier et
d'autres artistes et puis moi je m'en
rendais pas compte parce que je parle
beaucoup et il y a un journaliste il me
dit un moment il va souvent
ton artiste aux toilettes pardon
je suis allé voir ce qui se passait en
bas et la porte était pas fermée
qu'est-ce que tu fais là c'est moi à
l'époque j'avais 30 ans et je savais pas
la côte c'était
c'est même pas
d'actualité je savais même pas de cette
histoire
mais je me suis rattrapé malheureusement
parce que c'est vraiment de la merde
pas avec ça non mais c'est vrai
en fait alors moi à mon avis il a
commencé vers 19h30 c'est ça qui est
incroyable
34 ans
au palais des glaces
et moi je me suis rendu compte c'est au
mois de septembre je me suis appelé au
mois de juin au festival ou mais au
Festival de Cannes
donc mais il faut le laisser
je sais pas pour le dédouaner encore
mais je voudrais pas être à sa place
dans sa tête bien sûr
si j'ai accepté de venir vous m'avez
appelé trois fois dix jours
il m'a rappelé ce matin il m'a dit que
vous en aviez parlé et puis j'ai vu ce
matin j'étais en forme j'avais rien pris
une blague
évite les blagues
sur le récit t'emmerde pas
donc non j'avais pas
ce qui m'aurait coûté
il sera puni mais je trouve que il
s'appellerait pas Pierre Palmade il
serait traité un peu différemment ça
sera
à peu près 600 morts comme ça par an 700
familles de victimes
j'aimerais bien qu'on parle de mon cas
aussi